hello and welcome everyone thank you for
joining us for today's webinar
liquid-based microbiology simplify
sample collection and transport to
improve patient care presented by dr.
susan sharp scientific directors Copan
diagnostics i'm christy jewel of
laberd's and I'll be your moderator for
today's event we're delighted to bring
you this educational web seminar
presented by lab roots and sponsored by
Cove and Diagnostics
to learn more about our sponsor please
visit copay on usa.com before we begin I
would like to remind everyone that this
event is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want during the
presentation simply click on the ask a
question box type in your questions and
click send we'll answer as many of your
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation if you have trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation
please use the ask a question box to let
us know you're experiencing a problem
this presentation is educational and the
software's continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits our speaker today is dr. Susan
sharp for a complete biography on our
speaker please visit the biography tab
at the top of your screen now without
further ado please join me in welcoming
dr. Susan sharp dr. sharp you may now
begin your presentation
you
Thank You Christy hello everyone I'm dr.
sue sharp and thank you for joining us
today for this seminar and I'd like to
thank Bob Ruth's for sponsoring the
WebEx and for the venue in which to
speak to you today about liquid based
microbiology
we know clinical microbiology is
undergoing changes not only in specimen
collection processing and incubation but
also in the way we work up our cultures
with the advent of digital imaging
algorithms and artificial intelligence
we have a lot of changes coming ahead
and we know clinical microbiology is
chasing is facing some big challenges
out there we have increased workload
associated with hospital-associated
infections testing for the emerging
antibiotic resistance of bacteria
laboratory consolidation and there's a
pressure a pressure for shorter patient
length of stay which means for us we
need to have more rapid results and
we're trying to do all this in the face
of decreasing resources we know we're
getting paid less for the tests that we
are performing laboratory consolidations
often time comes with additional
workload but not necessarily additional
staff to help with that workload we're
facing an ageing workforce and
retirements from clinical microbiology
and there's a lack of personnel entering
our profession in 2005 the American
Society for Microbiology did a
benchmarking study and they surveyed
clinical microbiology laboratories for
their work loads of productivity rates
and their staffing vacancies and at that
time 39 percent of laboratories had
vacant seats 50% of those vacancies took
three months to fill and 13% of those
vacancies required more than a year to
fill but things are improving this is a
similar survey done by the American
Society for clinical pathology in 2016
to 2017 we can say that the vacancy rate
in the laboratory is
down to about 6% about three months to
fill staff vacancies but it can take up
to a year to fill supervisory roles
and also this study shows us that over
the next five years and we're one year
into that five year period over 20
percent of clinical microbiologists are
due to retire so we definitely need to
find some efficiencies going forward
so what does this have to do with
specimen collection which is what we're
supposed to be discussing today well
clearly laboratories need to find
efficiencies as we stated laboratories
are under tremendous pressure to perform
quality testing while at the same time
limiting additional cost to the medical
institution so laboratories must your
teachers going to evaluate each sample
and streamline whenever possible and
this certainly can apply to specimen
collection and transportation products
slide I wanted to share with you as a
picture of the automated core lab line
at Kaiser Permanente in Portland Oregon
where I worked up until a couple of
years ago this line hole runs about 77%
of the 13 million annual test volume in
this laboratory and it's all sorted and
tested by automation
they have Auto loaders in the front of
these lines that can each handle 30,000
specimens per day and 80 percent of the
specimens that go onto this line are
Auto verified by the lis the laboratory
information system the technologists
never have to look at this result
and that's easy for them to do in our in
hematology chemistry and automated
immunology because all their specimens
look alike they all come in the same
size tube and they all have basically
the same consistencies but we know that
microbiology is unique we have very
challenging specimen we receive them in
various containers of various sizes and
this can make it much more difficult to
standardize and automate
so we're going to take a look at items
that are available to laboratorians that
will allow for liquid based microbiology
and learn how these types of specimen
collections can help us with the
efficiencies in the laboratory that we
know we badly need so let's start by
looking at squad we know we use swabs
for throat collections wound couples and
vaginal specimens among other types
now the state-of-the-art around the
1940s for swabs was essentially what you
see here a q-tip this was cotton wrapped
around a wooden stick and the inhibitory
effects of the materials used in these
swabs who really not been studied and
there was no data on the uptake of the
specimens into these swabs or the
release of the specimen from the swab
producing a more standardized approach
for collection and transportation of
specimens using swabs was really a new
concept and no one had ever really
thought much about how to improve this
process and there hadn't been much
research done in this area either
the first publish standard didn't arrive
for another 60 years but in 2003 the
NLCS which we now know as the CLS I
published a document known as the m-40
it was entitled quality control for
Microbiology transport systems and it
outlined international standards for
collection and transport devices no one
had ever really questioned the standard
transport swab or how we might be able
to improve it but these new standards
created a new performance challenge for
squad manufacturers the purpose of the
m-40 was to set out guidance criteria
for the four manufacturers that produce
transport devices including urine
specimen containers blood culture
bottles and collection and transport
swabs the same criteria were also
intended to assist in users and
assessing the relative performance
characteristics of the available
collection devices
the essential requirement of this
document was to show that the
microbiology integrity of a patient's
specimen was being maintained in a
stable manner during any anticipated
transport period or transport conditions
in the case of transport swabs and
collection swabs
it was guidance to show that live
microorganisms remained viable without a
drastic increase or decrease in numbers
during transport to the laboratory their
survival of air robes and robes and
fastidious organisms was assessed for up
to 48 hours at either ambient
temperature or refrigeration
temperatures and any limitations for a
collection device that was found needs
to be clearly stated by the manufacturer
now with traditional fiber squads as
shown here yards of fiber are wrapped
around an applicator stick now much of
the specimen when we take a specimen
with one of these swabs it can become
trapped in the mattress of the swab and
it is not very efficiently then released
into either transport media or onto
culture plates as only approximately
three to five percent of the specimen
can actually be recovered from a
collection device like this
now in trying to produce a better
collection swab copan found that the
spacing of the fibers on the tip of the
swab was important not only to ensure
that the specimen is collected as
efficiently as possible but also that
the specimen is eluded from the swab in
the most efficient manner and there was
also a need to understand the types of
fibers that were used the glues that
were used and the stem and to determine
if any of this might be inhibitory to
certain types of organisms or if they
could interfere with certain test
systems
swab was invented in 2003 it consists of
a unique plastic applicator with a
molded rounded tip and onto this tip
thousands of short strands of nylon are
applied in a perpendicular fashion using
a flocking process these flock slobs
have no internal mattress core to entrap
a sample like we see with traditional
swabs and using a flock swab the entire
sample stays very close to the surface
and as much as 90 percent of the sample
automatically eludes from the sois swab
when you touch it to the surface of a
plate or when you place it into
transport medium
suave is a combination of a flock swap
plus one mil of liquid Ami's media and a
plastic screw cap tube these swabs allow
for more than 90% of the specimen to be
alluded into the Aimee's media it is
used as a collection and transport
device for aerobic anaerobic and pass
phidias bacteria for up to 48 hours and
we should note as is displayed here in
the slide that the exception for this
48-hour rule is with Neisseria gonorrhea
but which is stable for up to 24 hours
as flock slobs at least salute almost
the entire sample upon contact with the
amys media there is equal sample
distribution across all your media
plates which will allow for better
growth better recovery of organisms and
for more isolated colonies and flock
slobs provide a more homogeneous
specimen preparation for better and
easier to read grants names these swabs
not only can be used for traditional
gram staining and bacterial culture but
they can also be used for automated
specimen processing platforms
rapid antigen testing and many molecular
assays
these laws can also allow for simplified
ordering of supplies and will allow
easier training of personnel in the
specimen collection process there's no
more confusion regarding which swab to
select to use with which tests it can
all be the same collection device if
you're using a flock swab this will also
mean streamline processes for the
laboratories as we now will be able to
process a single type of swab rather
than multiple different types of
traditional swabs
as flex wads collect and release more
specimen for routine cultures they allow
us to significantly improve patient test
results again through butter gram
stain's
and the potential for an earlier
preliminary patient diagnosis plus as a
block swab it continues one mill of
liquid Ami's media they decrease the
need for repeat testing due to
insufficient two sample size blocks was
have been shown in the literature to
increase the sensitivity of screening
assays used in the laboratory and as an
example the study shown here compared
the use of double Dacron swab with slack
swabs in the screening for staph aureus
from naval cultures both types of swabs
were collected from 50 healthy
volunteers one of the double daikon swab
was planted directly onto blood auger
and the second was a vortex in 1.8
Millis a lean and then 18 microliters
was planted onto a blood agar plate the
floc swab media was planted using a la
crosse of 8 again 18 microliters and
also 30 microliters and all of the
plates from both swabs for comparison
were reviewed after 24 and 48 hours of
incubation for colonies of
Staphylococcus aureus
the sensitivity of the direct Dacron
swab with 66.7% the sensitivity of the
Dacron swab that was diluted in sailing
on decreased down to 60% using the 18
microliters of media from the flock swab
the sensitivity with 47.7% but with
using 30 microliters from the flock swab
collection the sensitivity increased to
80 6.7% thus this study shows that flock
slobs
when used in 30 mil aliquot can detect
up to 20% more cases of Staphylococcus
aureus nasal colonization as compared to
routine swab collections
now the purpose of this study was to
evaluate whether specimens collected
with swash swabs can being used for
direct testing of Group B Strep during
pregnancy by molecular assays the
authors wanted to determine if a more
sensitive method for testing of Group B
Strep at the time of admission might
lead to better detection of colonization
closer to the time of delivery now in
this study they used mock specimens and
they were prepared at different organism
concentrations to determine whether
direct SLAC swabs yielded equivalent
sensitivity to routine swab collections
and they compared these to overnight
enriched broth cultures as well
the top panel shows the positivity rate
of four replicas samples at various
groovy strip concentrations when tested
directly from the flocks wad media using
500 micro 500 microliters of specimen in
the molecular assay
pecking the flax wad media they were
able to detect organisms down to a level
of 1.5 times 10 to the power 2 colony
forming units per mil this was compared
to the use of the routine rayon swabs
which had been incubated overnight in
limb broth and then tested using 15
microliters of the enriched culture as
was specified in the product insert for
the test the results were this er seen
in the lower panel
the root and rayon swabs incubated
overnight in limb broth were only able
to detect down to the level of 1.5 times
10 to the power of 4 colony forming
units per mil so this study demonstrated
a hundredfold higher sensitivity when
using the slack swab collections as
compared to routine swab collections and
overnight live incubation for the
recovery of Group A streptococcus ID
this study also showed that the direct
testing of flax swabs without overnight
enrichment broth was not only more
sensitive but it would could decrease
the turnaround time for test results by
approximately 90% so from 24 hours when
you would have to enrich the culture and
over inka night incubate overnight down
to two hours and this could make it
possible to use a very sensitive direct
test for women that present to delivery
without being pre-screened previously
to support laboratory centralization
which can cause longer transit times to
specimens Tyrell and colleagues looked
at anaerobic collection and transport
systems to determine if they were robust
enough to ensure the viability of
anaerobes for at least up to 48 hours
this study looked at classic and aerobic
transport system which consisted of
Rayanna array on swab together with an
anaerobic semi-solid Aimee's auger
transport tube and they compared this to
the east swab using a liquid Ami's for
anaerobic organism transportation
I tested 2015 yes anaerobic organisms
that are shown on this slide and they
consisted of nine gram positives and
eleven gram negative organisms and these
organisms were from various sources
ranging from oral specimens such as
tonsillar abscesses and facial lesions
sinus and sputum specimens to abdominal
and perirectal abscess --is diabetic
foot ulcers organisms from the X the
appendix stool specimens and even
included sterile sources like blood
cultures
the study consisted of using 24 and 48
hours subcultures of each organism that
would suspend it in sailing to a
turbidity of 0.5 McFarland the
suspension was used with each slide
system to determine organism recovery at
both room temperature and at 40 degrees
after storage for 24 and 48 hours at all
sampling times each suspension with
cereal and diluted placed onto Brucella
agar and incubated anaerobically for up
to 72 hours at 37 degrees after which
time colony counts were performed
this is a representative example of
organism recovery with six of the grand
negative error ropes that were tested in
the study you can see that at both room
temperature and at four degrees when
tested after inoculation at time zero
and 24 and 48 hours of incubation the
flack swab maintained similar or better
average viability as compared to the
classic anaerobic swab collection and
this same pattern was found when
reviewing the results for the rest of
the anaerobic organisms that were used
in this study
so in conclusion these authors state
that the east wob is an all-in-one
collection device that was shown to
provide equal or superior relief
viability and recovery performance for
up to 48 hours at both room temperature
and at 4 degrees with the most
fastidious anaerobic bacteria as
compared to the classic anaerobic
transport system in addition they
commented that unlike the classic
anaerobic swabs with the gel media
semi-solid gel media the flux wad
provided the added ability to be used in
automated specimen processing
instrumentation
and this study just shows that there was
one researcher they wanted to look at
the prevalence a few though bacterium
across from in children presenting to
their emergency room the signs and
symptoms of pharyngitis they collected
East wand on all of these throats from
these children and they were able to
complete eight tests on several cultures
some point-of-care a phase and a couple
of PCR assays so again eight tests were
be able to complete be completed from
one swap collection
Gandhian colleagues wanted to look at
the use of flux swabs for fungal isolate
so in this study they tested a total of
19 bumble organisms by again making a
point five mcfarland turbidity standard
for each of them plating these
suspensions over time and performing
colony counts they included in the study
six yeast isolates three dermatophytes
five highland moles which included two
Aspergillus species and an isolated
Fusarium three cycle my seeds and three
DeMatteis moles their results showed
that colony counts equal to or greater
than those seen at time zero were
obtained for all of these organisms and
they were able to conclude that the e
swab effectively maintained B fungi for
up to 48 hours so along with aerobic and
fastidious organisms anaerobes and fungi
can also be appropriately collected and
transported using east woggs
now this is another interesting study
again performed by Gandhi and his
colleagues that looked at the
performance of East Schwab's when used
to study the viability of
non-tuberculous mycobacteria which can
cause skin and soft-tissue infections
they stated very various concentrations
of the five different
non-tuberculous mycobacteria on te swabs
and tested them at time zero and
compared that to storage at four 24 and
48 hours at both room temperature and
four degrees
they found that compliance with the
Salus item 40 document was met by all
five of these isolates when stored at
four degrees both at 24 and 48 hours of
incubation in addition compliance was
also met with all five isolates tested
at room temperature storage again for
both 24 and 48 hours of incubation which
a single exception of Mycobacterium
marinum which did show over growth but
only after 48 hours of storage they
concluded that the east wob was shown to
maintain these micro bacterial isolates
that are known to cause skin and
soft-tissue infections and hence could
be sampled with swabs they were able to
show that they maintained them with high
efficiency for up to at least 48 hours
at both room temperature and
refrigeration temperature
so we've just taken a really good look
at slack swabs so now let's take a look
at some other new innovative specimen
collection and transport devices and
let's start by looking at stool specimen
currently after collecting a single
sample a quantity typically one to two
grams of feces is transferred into a
transport media tube as you can see here
using a spork
that's provided in the kit and this
process can be a little unpleasant and a
little messy
but with a newly developed liquid based
microbiology collection devices for
stool samples you can transfer the
optimal amount of the sample using an e
swab and then place this into a tube
which contains your carry blur transport
media there's no messy spork or bulky
transport containers to deal with it
also converts the semi-solid people
matter into liquid suspension for easy
laboratory automation and these devices
can also be made to be used as direct
rectal swabs as well these devices can
be used for most enteric molecular
assays as well including bacteria
viruses and parasites any of those
products that have indicates that you
can use kerry blair transport media
this study published last year looked at
the recovery of enteric pathogens as
well as commensal fecal flora after
storage in East wad for 24 48 and 72
hours again at room temperature and
refrigerated temperatures and they
compared this to storage in routine
carry blur media
they also looked at these samples after
plating with the Copan wasp automated
specimen processing instrument and
compared this with plating with a
semi-automated isolator instrumentation
and i'll get back to that in just a
minute
at 4 degrees storage at 24 48 and 72
hours both systems showed 100% survival
of most of the enteric pathogens with
the exception of the camp of actor
species in both systems it showed
marginal growth of these organisms at 24
and no growth at 48 hours and we know
that Campylobacter can be very finicky
organisms in trying to maintain them
but the real large difference was seen
with room temperature storage at 24
hours of storage at room temperature the
fecal swab recovered 6 out of 7
organisms at the same inoculum scene at
0 our plating and this was compared to
the kerry Blair medium in which only 2
out of 7 organisms were recovered in the
same quantities as the 0 outer plating
at 48 hours of storage the fecal floss
log showed one log increase for
Salmonella typhi your stadia and e.coli
and this compared to the routine Kerry
Blair medium which showed over growth of
3 log or more increase with these same
three organisms
looked at and showed the comparative
growth of the normal fecal flora between
the two collection devices again not
much difference is seen at four degrees
as shown on the right side of the graph
however at room temperature
although the fecal swab showed increases
of twelve percent and one hundred and
forty four percent after six and twenty
four hours respectively this was
compared to increases in the carry blur
media at the same time periods of 290
and over 500 percent
these authors concluded that the sequel
swab was superior in limiting the
overgrowth of chemical flora
especially if specimens are being held
at room temperature and that's the
chance of isolating single colonies of
pathogens was greater in specimens
stored in the fecal swab as it showed
less overgrowth of the fecal flora
this is a study that was done by Kim
Chapin and colleague who looked at the
performance of liquid based fecal swabs
in a pediatric emergency department the
objective of this study was to evaluate
the use of the rectal swab swab
collected at the time of the patient
visit and compare the results of this
collection method to the results of
stool samples that were submitted in
carry blur medium the assay used for
comparison or for comparing these two
collection methods was a multiplex
molecular panel for the rapid detection
of gastrointestinal pathogens the bio
fire assay 190 rackleff lakh swabs and
carry blur stool specimens were
collected at three separate Hospital
sites
and these were compared overall
agreement between the paired collections
for pathogen detection was 82%
there were 32 additional pathogens that
were detected only from the carry blur
stool specimen and an additional 26
pathogens that were detected only from
the rectal flock swab
so these authors concluded that the
performance of the retroflex lob
collection device was comparable to the
routine carry bear carry flare
collection for the tection of GI
pathogen using this multiplex molecular
platform and they stated that the retro
fecal swab would allow for sample
collection at the time of patient visit
and the generation of actionable results
through the majority of significant
infections in their acute care setting
when a stool specimen could not be
provided
we know that carry blue medium contains
auger which is derived from seaweed
which is not an issue for culture as we
are looking to grow live organisms
however when we're using molecular tests
we are looking for nucleic acids which
can be found in non-viable
microorganisms and we know that the high
sensitivity is some of these molecular
assays may result in false positive
results caused by the presence of
nucleic acids in the seaweed that
contained the non viable organisms that
can be found in Keri Blair but hope
hanzo's vigorous QC testing and has
recently announced that the fecal swab
will be supplied with their
certification stating that no detectable
levels of nucleic acids of the most
common GI pathogens can be found in the
medium
okay so now let's take a look at
collection and transport of sputum
samples and I'm not sure about all of
you but sputum specimens are my least
favorite type of specimens to process
sputum is a viscoelastic semi-solid
substance made up of mucus and
leukocytes and cellular debris and
inflammatory mediators elastin fibers
etc and it can be difficult to process
these specimens onto auger plates or to
make grande stains from them as they're
so tenacious in their consistency so
oftentimes it's necessary to add a
liquefying agent or a mucolytic agent
onto the sputum in order to release the
bacteria that may be trapped within that
very complex network of sputum and
there's a variety of mucolytic agents
that exist but died file 3 at all or dtt
and n-acetylcysteine or the two most
widely used these to contain a
sulfhydryl group that cleaves the
dualsaw fide bond that links used use
and molecules together and therefore
they decrease the viscosity of the
specimen and studies have shown that
sputum liquification
with low concentrations of dtt is more
effective than an acetal l-cysteine with
a 90% reduction in sputum elasticity and
a greater number of organisms are
recovered
the snot buster is a novel collection
device that offers dtt liquefying
solution and are ready to use to with an
effective sputum tool for collecting the
most viscous part of the sputum sample
now this product can produce less waste
it can be very cost-efficient for the
laboratory and we know that traditional
sputum liquefying solutions are normally
made up in very large batches they're
usually only good for about 48 hours so
every couple of days you have to make
more of these solutions but with this
novel product which is room temperature
stable it creates a homogeneous
suspension of the sputum in the mucus
with which then can be planted manually
or can easily be placed on an automated
processing instrument the media does not
affect the morphology of the cells or
the pathogen of the Gram stain and it
would allow any for any normal growth of
any bacteria that are present in the
sample so there's no messy bulky
reagents to prepare to prepare and it's
quick and easy to liquefy even the most
nasty of sputum samples
okay so urine is the next specimen on
our list to discuss ideally we know that
urine specimen should be transported to
the laboratory and plated within two
hours of collection however we know that
that's not always possible in mating
institutions especially for those that
have laboratories that might be located
off-site
refrigeration of temperature within 30
minutes of collection is also acceptable
storage for up to 24 hours but
oftentimes even refrigeration of urines
is not easy to comply with and some
sites collect an overwhelming number of
URIs and oftentimes don't have enough
refrigerator space to adequately store
some of these samples so due to the
issues associated with transport and
storage of urine urine many laboratories
have elected to use a collection device
or a transfer device that has preserved
it in it as you can see here in the
middle these vacuum spells containers
transfer urine into boric acid tubes
boric acid is the urine stabilizing
agent contained in these tubes and this
can be accomplished at the clinic or on
the floor or in the core laboratory but
it can still be somewhat time consuming
to manage the process of taking the
urine and putting them each in these
vacutainer tube
this novel device is called the uri
sponge and it uses an applicator stick
that has two cylindrical shaped sponges
with urine preservatives embedded into
the sponges the device is used to is use
by simply dipping the sponge into the
collected urine and then placing it into
the transport tube
there's no fill line necessary as there
is for your boric acid to the collection
device is designed to allow for the
exact right mixture of urine and
preservative and the sponge will hold
approximately 2 mils of urine now the
tube will maintain the viability of
bacteria at both refrigerated
temperatures and room temperatures for
up to 48 hours
this is a study that was done by Bob
Reni Adel in Canada that showed that the
sponge device when compared to urine
culture paddles maintain significantly
more urinary pathogens and showed fewer
mixed cultures and fewer contaminated
cultures in addition they compared the
uri sponge to boric acid transport tubes
and they found favorable outcomes with
regard with regards to maintenance of
the viability of the pathogen and the
uri sponge also showed fewer mixed
cultures
so I think we can now start to
appreciate the ability of our colleagues
in our corn laboratories and how they
can test so many samples so efficiently
of liquid-based microbiology collection
devices microbiology is also poised to
be able to obtain these efficiencies
and I think we can see how these
products can change the way we perform
microbiology in our clinical
laboratories
the variety of collection and transport
containers that are now available liquid
based microbiology and automations
are clearly possible and are currently
being used by many clinical laboratories
in the US Canada and Europe liquid based
microbiology collection devices will
allow for a simplified streamlined
collection to provide better results to
optimize patient care and as East Watts
and other novel collection devices have
opened the door for liquid based
microbiology and turn liquid based
microbiologists open the door for
automated specimen processing and Co
pans lbm products will allow for the
optimization of your automated specimen
processing instrumentation the primary
point on this slide is to point out that
the amount of Campylobacter recovered
from stool specimens after the
implementation of an automated specimen
processor in this case it was the previ
isolator was significantly increased as
compared to manual inoculations in
looking at two years before and two
years after the implementation of
automation this study showed the
recovery of Campylobacter isolates in
the pre automation time period with 29
vs. sixty-four isolates in the post
automation period
now coming back to the study we discuss
using sequel slots as compared to
routine carry blur collection devices
this study also looked at these
specimens when placed onto a fully
automated lost instrument and compares a
recovery of isolated pathogens to that
when a semi-automated isolator
instrument was used
the authors also concluded from this
study that the fecal swab used in
conjunction with the wasp instrument was
superior to the semi-automated
isolator method and that the wasps
provided a higher number of isolated
pathogens compared to commensal colonies
they say that this could allow for
immediate identification of pathogens
without the need for further subculture
which will help us decrease our
turnaround time for our results
this 2016 study looked at urine
specimens and automated specimen
processing and they demonstrated among
other things that one drinking by
automated specimen processing
instrumentation with superior to manual
streaking with regard to the number of
isolated colonies and two it showed that
automated processing can lead to the
detection of a higher number of
different morphologies different species
and overall pathogens from urine
specimens and the authors were able to
conclude that the results of this study
point to an improved quality of
microbiology analysis and laboratory
reports when using automated
instrumentation
in this study approximately 100 rectal
vaginal specimens from pregnant women
were collected in parallel using a rayon
fiber swab which was then placed into
liquid Stuart's media as well as
collection onto East one each collection
device was used to do two things
directly directly and Nightblade culture
plate and then they replace discussed
was replaced in tool in broth for
overnight incubation
the sensitivity of the directly planted
east swab which were processed by
automated instrumentation with ninety
three point eight percent this compared
to the sensitivity of the directly
planted rayon swabs that were manually
process which was eighty seven point
five percent
this is a difference of over 6% in the
detection of Group B Strep during
pregnancy screening between these two
collection and processing systems
and although the percentages did
increase 3% for both swab groups after
overnight limb enrichment cultures that
6% difference in sensitivity remained
between the two collection and
processing methods even after broth
enrichment
our automated specimen processing also
have added benefits they improve our
quality and accuracy of our specimen
inoculation it's always been the same
way every time again we talked about
getting better isolated colonies for
better detection of pathogens which will
decrease our time to result and
hopefully improve patient care
it also allows excellence basement
specimen traceability improved
ergonomics due to the decrease in
repetitive motion injuries which
hopefully should lead to increased
efficiency and productivity by our
laboratory staff
the liquid based microbiology has made
automated specimen processing possible
and in turn automated specimen
processing opens another really large
door to full laboratory automation in
clinical microbiology and this brings us
to wasp lab which you can see in the
picture here
with wasps lab you can have those same
bulks orders at the front of the line as
I said we're in the front of our Corps
line at Kaiser this is for a streamline
specimen loading it will automatically
it's a bowl order you can drop all the
tubes in there it will automatically
store the specimens and send them where
they need to go so there's no batching
that's necessary
and we know that the wasp allows for
customized drinking patterns that can be
user-defined and that can even perform
dual streaks planting both sides of any
by plates simultaneously after the
plates are processed by the wasp they go
on to the tracks and are sent to the
smart incubators via conveyor track
and we know when ventures when our
plates are sitting on a bench they're
not incubating and we know when we come
in the morning we take our place out we
send them on the bench we may do a
little QC we start our work up we go to
coffee place you're still on the bench
we come back from coffee break we work
up and serve our cultures we handle a
few phone calls we take our lunch we
come back the place are still sitting on
the bench I think you can see what I'm
trying to get out here whenever the
plates are sitting on the bench the
organisms are growing much slower
however when we have our organisms in
our smart incubators each plate has a
unique location as you can see here
they're not stacked in canisters 12 or
10 auger plates deep they all get the
exact same atmospheric conditions and
the same thermal conductivity this
should allow us to read our plates even
faster since there's continuous
incubation of our plates not only are
they're not sitting on the bench top
there aren't people constantly getting
in and out of the incubator changing the
environmental conditions on the inside
with regard to not only temperature but
also atmospheric requirements as well
so with full mob automation again our
place are always incubating it will
allow for more rapid growth of colonies
and hence we'll be able to work up our
cultures sooner
with full lab automation imaging it's
very important the imaging times that
the pictures or the images that are
captured of the plates can be sent by
the user you may want to have images
taken of your urine cultures for example
at 12 14 or 16 hours sputum you may want
to have images taken at 24 or 48 hours
but with the continuous incubation that
full of automation offers I think we're
going to see a paradigm shift where
we're going to be able to again work up
these cultures much sooner than we did
before so the common incubation times
that we know of now for different types
of specimens in the laboratory will most
definitely decrease in the future
here you can see that the rather than
looking at the place themselves you look
at images of the place as you can see
here and then the digital image on the
place are displayed on the screen
colonies can be selected automatically
with instructions for each colony and
what you want done with that colony or
the plates can be sent for other
automatic processes or you can get the
place at your bench if it is something
you feel like you need to look at
individually
um there's also colony picking
instrumentation that can be used for
identification and susceptibility
testing this is a Calibri instrument
from copan that can spot your MALDI
plates and then add your matrix to the
place the MALDI plates they're ready to
go in the instrumentation can also
prepare 1/2 McFarland standards for both
identification and susceptibility
testing as well as doing subculture and
Roth subcultures for you
this was some data from dr. Chris a
Cobra's laboratory at tricor
laboratories that wanted to look at the
impact of lab automation on their FTEs
and they took three different chores
that they did in the laboratory they've
selected urine screening and reading
urine picking and MRF a culture
screening to see what difference they
could see before they brought on
automation and after they brought on
automation
now this laboratory was not using a
Calibri picker so you can see there's no
difference really in the time they spent
on picking the organisms out of their
urine to do more work on but we said
pretty dramatic difference in the amount
of time they had to spend in training
and reading their urine and also in
screening and reading their MRF a
cultures so before and after
implementation they saw that they could
normally were spending about 17 hours on
these three tasks and they were able to
decrease that down to nine hours a day
after implementation of lab automation
here they also wanted to look at the
financial impact for curing cultures
before they automated brought automation
into the laboratory they were spending
on annual labor just to do urines over
ninety thousand dollars a year after
bringing in the wasp they saw that they
decreased that in half so post
automation they were spending about
forty five thousand dollars a year on
labor to perform urine cultures and they
also wanted to extend this out looking
at pre and post wasp lab implementation
and they wanted to project this out to
the year 2020 as you can see they
brought on their wasp in 2016 and they
were able to project us out looking at a
15 percent growth they saw that if they
had not brought front on automation that
by the year 2020 they would be spending
over a hundred and forty thousand
dollars in labor just to do urine
cultures but after bringing on the wasp
blob in 2020 they expect to be spending
much less to have less than half of that
at about seventy thousand dollars to do
the labor associated with their urine
cultures so as automated specimen
processing has opened the door to full
laboratory automation and clinical
microbiology lab automation itself opens
a really big door to digital
microbiology artificial intelligence
interpretive algorithms that can all
assist us in how we do work up in our
laboratory copán has a software they
were they utilize artificial
intelligence and interpretive algorithms
and this software is called the pheno
matrix software and we can use the pheno
matrix software to help with chroma
genic detection of organisms urine
culture segregation based on colony
counts and colony recognition on
standardized media and this is a whole
nother lecture to talk to you about the
the advances that this software can give
us in the laboratory which I'd love to
give to you someday as well
so we've already touched on that unlike
our colleagues and chemistry and
hematology and immunology the
microbiology laboratory receives all
kinds of specimens and all kinds of
specimen containers with all different
kinds of consistencies but with the
presentation today I hope I've been
pressed upon you that liquid based
microbiology can very efficiently and
very effectively handle the vast
majority of specimens we encounter each
day in our microbiology laboratories in
summary there's innovation collection
devices allow for better specimen
collection ease a supply ordering and
simple training of our users they allow
for multiple tests to be performed from
one sample and they absolutely are
leading the way towards automated
specimen processing so from liquid based
specimen collection to automated
specimen processing to the use of smart
incubators the lab automation including
digital imaging artificial intelligence
and interpretive algorithms we are very
much in a very exciting time in clinical
microbiology today and with that I'll
end here I'd like to take again lab
routes for assisting us and putting this
webinar together and most of all I'd
like to thank all of you for listening
today and with that I'd be happy to
answer any questions
you
Thank You dr. Sharpe for the
informative presentation and welcome to
Amanda Schmidt marketing manager copán
Diagnostics will be joining us for our
live question-and-answer session now
just a quick reminder to our audience on
how to submit questions simply type them
into the ask a question box and click
the send button we will answer as many
questions as we have time for okay our
first question is could a red-top copán
tube be used for both the streaking of
blood cultures on the wasp and for the
bc ID okay thanks for the question
the Copan red cap tubes are certainly
appropriate to be used for blood cow
blood culture a loquats to be used on
the wasp instrumentation and we're
pretty sure and we think that they would
also be acceptable for aliquot use for
BC ID as well very good thank you dr.
Sharpe our next question can fecal flaw
be used with all multiplex molecular
testing of stools looking for
gastrointestinal gastrointestinal
pathogens
yes fecal swab up stated contained carry
blur medium so as long as the testing
product states that a carry Blair
preserved specimen can be used in their
assay then yes equal swabs can also be
used again the medium in the sequel swab
is carry Blair
now dr. sharp can urine from that you're
a sponge be used for a chemical analysis
and microscopic testing
yeah thanks that's a good question
the URI sponge can be used for
microscopic analysis however due to the
de boric acid and the sodium formate
that is in the sponge it cannot be used
for chemical analysis like your chemist
rips or your dipsticks etc and this is
the same with any urine specimen that
you would put in for cast preservative
regardless of what kind of a collection
or transport device that you would have
it in
dr. sharp what about automation for
tissue specimens is there a collection
device that can be placed directly on an
automated processing instrumentation
another excellent question we know that
tissues is something we didn't address
it is an issue that we have in the
laboratory that would be great to be
able to have an automated process for
currently there are disposable grinder
tubes on that can be used to still
manually grind the tissues and then
these grinder tubes can then be kept and
placed on the wasp instrument for the
automated specimen processing part so
the wasp is able to decap the grinder to
take the cap off and sample the specimen
it will sample using a 30 micro liter
loop and put that on each plate so
although the initial grinding is skin is
still manual the wasp instrument would
be able to handle on the tube that you
read that you cap and put back on the
instrumentation and it would be able to
handle the plate inoculation and the
streaking on those samples
okay thank you dr. sharp let's see our
next question
oK we've got somebody coming in the mail
you look through here no this is two
parts my lab is interested in moving to
East slob for culture testing and
potentially for some of our molecular
tests first part of the question can you
talk about validation or verification
work that needs to be done when making
the switch sure if you're switching
swabs for culture and Gram stain say
you're switching from using your routine
rayon or fiber swab to an e swab then
there's no reason to do a verification
that's just a standalone collection
device and you do not have to compare
that to the routine swab that you're
using now and if the e swab is also in
the product insert for any test kit or
any test assay then again it does not
need to be verified separately from the
verification you would do for the
routine test kit verification up front
however if there is a kit test or a kit
assay that does not list I swap among
their acceptable collection devices then
yes the verification would be necessary
as you would be using that kit or that
test off of the FDA label but keep in
mind certainly a director can choose to
do any kind of verification testing that
they would like even if it's not
mandatory
now dr. sharp here's part two of that
question does cocaine provide any
training support for our point of care
providers oh yeah absolutely we we know
that change management management can be
a challenge with any kind of a new
product that you bring into the
laboratory and we're very happy to make
available to use instructional guides
and videos as well as to have training
for your clinicians or your providers or
for your laboratory staff on how to use
the new collection devices and we can
also have someone develop the help with
any verifications that you may feel that
you need to do before implementing one
of the collection devices
next question can I swap to be used for
LBC and viral pathogen molecular testing
again I'm not sure what LBC stands for
but I'll answer the viral molecular
pathogen testing again as I just stated
you can use an East mob in a in a viral
molecular pathogen testing panel if the
e swab has been if the e swab is in the
FDA label for being able to use in there
along with any other acceptable devices
if it is not listed among the acceptable
devices by the FDA then you would have
to perform a verification testing
in-house before you could use the e swab
with that particular panel
okay our next question we are not an
automated micro lab what is the best way
to play these various tubes and do we
use Lube swabs pipettes or something
else that's a good question yeah you can
use any of these obviously any of these
collection devices whether or not that
you have laboratory automation to do the
processing for you the best way to use
them that you can it's really up to you
certainly with the urine cultures you
would want to do calibrated loops
because you'll want to get your urine
concentration and your colony counts up
with your with your urine so yes with
the URI sponge you definitely would want
to use a calibrated loop with with wound
swabs and stool swabs etc you can use
you can use a pipette or you can
actually use the the east wob itself by
dipping it back into the container
between plates so either way is
acceptable using a pipette is acceptable
and putting drops on your plates for
your manual streaking or again you can
do the East squad music swab itself for
inoculating the plate but if you are
going to use the e swab directly you
want to make sure since the East wha
does elude most of the specimen off of
the the swab when you touch the plate
you want to make sure you're going back
into the specimen between each plate
Thank You dr. Sharpe and it looks like
we have time for one more question our
final question of the day I would like
to know if it is possible to use the
samples we collected from an HPV
sampling for both HPV detection and
microbiology tests
and that's a good question and I'm not
sure I know the answer to that so I'm
going to kick that over to manda to see
if she knows
I don't but we can certainly look into
that and see what the email of that
asker and we'll get that answer for you
thank you now Amanda and dr. sharp we
want to thank you for joining us and we
also want to thank our audience for
joining us today and for their
interesting questions questions we did
not have time for today and those
submitted during our on-demand period
will be addressed via the contact
information you provided at the time of
registration now before we go on dr.
sharp Amanda do either of you have any
final comments for our audience yeah I
would just like to once again thank lab
roots for this opportunity to present
this interesting information to you on
liquid based microbiology and again
thank the audience for listening today
thank you both and we'd also like to
thank averts and our sponsor copán
Diagnostics for underwriting today's
educational webcast this webcast can be
viewed on-demand and laborat swill alert
you via email when it's available for
replay we encourage you to share that
email with your colleagues who may have
missed today's live event now that's all
for now and thanks for joining us and we
hope to see you again next time goodbye
you